So it's my absolute pleasure to introduce
my friend and author and Speaker
Nilofer, um, Nyla fan. I met, um,
about seven years ago at Ted in Europe.
Um,
and when I moved to the bay
area, she said, oh, look me up.
And I thought that's the kind of thing
that Americans say when you moved to the
bay area. But when I called her
up, um, she said, absolutely,
I'm going to throw a
dinner party have for you.
And she threw a dinner party for me with
10 women who then became friends and
we're sort of like the beginning of my,
my friends and my
network and the bay area.
So I've been eternally grateful for that.
Um,
she also introduced me to the concept
of walk walking meetings instead of
sitting meetings,
which absolutely transformed my life.
So I've been pacing around Martin
with you ever since. Um, so,
and that's actually like her super top
rated Ted talk is a very short talk about
how walking is important because
otherwise sitting is the smoking of our
generation. So, um, she's written, um,
on a whole number of topics and,
um,
it's great to have her here to
talk to us about her latest book,
which is called the power
of loneliness, um, which is,
and she'll obviously tell you much more
about this concept and why she came up
with it, but it's BC about how each
of us is unique in their own right.
Um,
she's drawn from a whole load of different
examples of people she's interviewed
for the book but also from her sort of
own experience or working at companies
like Adobe and apple as well as
startups and the in the early days.
So she's got this sort of lick
really kind of a wide career.
And um,
she is now a recognized thinker and she
just told me that she's not like ranked
on the number, uh, as number 22 on the
top management thinker list. So. Well,
it's a pleasure to have you here and I'm
going to hand it over to you to try and
make these slides work. Just tell
you, tell us about your idea.
Thank you very much.
Thanks Toby.
Um,
so thank you for coming and actually for
all your patients through the last few
minutes.
And uh,
what I want to just do is share with
you a thesis about how the world can and
should be. And it starts
with something really simple.
I don't know if you guys have caught this,
but in the economist world right now,
there's a conversation
going on about ideas.
We've run out of ideas and therefore
productivity and prosperity is doomed
because specifically America
has run out of ideas.
And I don't know about you,
but I find that idea ridiculous because
actually my experience is just the
opposite. I bet yours is too.
Most ideas are dismissed,
not because they're considered
and evaluated and deemed unworthy,
but because of the packaging
that the idea comes in.
So if that person's super young or maybe
a woman in a male dominated culture or
person of color and a
mostly white culture or,
and fill out the list
however you choose to,
most ideas are dismissed because the
person who brings it lacks and status.
This problem that we have about ideas
being gone is so fundamental to our
economy. It's so fundamental to
our future. It's because ideas,
when we give them rain, pull us into the
future. And so if we don't have ideas,
we have nothing. And so here at Google
we know how ludicrous that idea is,
but we actually have to figure out how
to change the very framework by which we
evaluate ideas in order
for us to change the world.
And that's totally change our
ability to create the future.
Now one of the people, so I ob mentioned
that I did a bunch of research,
I actually studied 300 examples in
order to actually write this book.
I didn't mean to write to
have to study 300 examples,
but every single person I was studying
to understand how do they get their idea
through had a different idea
of what's made them successful.
Then what was actually true.
So there was no repeatable pattern and
tie study 302 I found the through line
and one of those stories is Franklin
Leonard Franklin started an organization
called the blacklist, which reinvented
Hollywood. But when he actually showed up,
he was this young, 20 something years
old guy. He had worked for a congressman,
he had worked at Mckinsey
and gotten fired.
And then he showed up at
Hollywood after get this,
he had done a weekend of Netflix binge
watching and realize the only thing you'd
ever really loved with storytelling
and movies. And so he thought,
I'll just show up in Hollywood
and figure out how to break in.
So he schlepped coffee.
And one of the jobs that junior
people do is to actually read scripts.
And he found most, the scripts
had these really trite, um,
storylines that just kind of repeated
the same heroic architecture and didn't
reflect the stories that he wanted to see
in the world. And one point he thought,
there's gotta be a different way.
That's what he went through his entire
Rolodex of people he had met in the last
year and literally like
went through and said, oh,
I saw this person for lunch and I saw
this person for dinner and organized an
89% email list under
an alias, Google. And,
uh,
actually send out a note saying,
if you share with me the movies that
you've seen in the last year that you've
loved but haven't been put into
production, excuse me, screen the screen,
like scripts,
not movies.
I will collate all that up using his
McKenzie skills and I will send it back to
you. So that's the give and the get
do that and let's see where it goes.
And people cooperate it.
In fact,
they shared it with friends and he ended
up doing this tabulation process only
because he wanted to find the
scripts his boss would need.
And the reason he used an alias is because
he didn't want his boss to think he
wasn't good at his job.
So he does this. He,
this is back in the days when we actually
all went on vacation and actually
logged off. So he printed off the top
five that he got from the master list.
It took off,
he comes back two weeks later and it's
inbox is full of this roll up lists.
This blacklist all sent
back to him saying,
this is the most amazing list of scripts
we should all be taking a look at it.
And so literally hundreds of emails are
in his inbox because no one knows it's
him that has started this
process. Now, if it was a build,
you see that some of the movies that had
been put into production because of the
black list, our Juno and I'm the king
speech, who would imagine, right?
And so these were the scripts that were
destined for the dustmen and pulled out
and put back on the master list of we
should really consider these odd ducky
stories.
Moonlight.
One of the things that Franklin did is
he asked a brand new question and I said
it in such a quick way
when I first rolled out,
what are the ask has people that it's
worth kind of pausing on. He asked,
what movies do you love that
haven't been put into production?
What scripts do you love?
And the reality is that's
not how Hollywood has been
formatted up to this point.
What's Hollywood sort on?
What will make us money?
And by doing it through an alias,
he actually found a community of people
who cared about the same question as
that, a different kind of
purpose, pulling people together.
And it provided enough anonymity that
people could essentially vote the way
their heartfelt not vote, the way
their boss might want them to vote.
And so it changed an
access of orientation.
And one of the things that shows us is
really the power of community in that
process, right? So often
we think about power,
the ability to get
things done as personal.
And so we'll often describe
like a Franklin in fact
gets featured in like fast
company and stuff as the guy,
as you know,
he changed Hollywood because he produced
the blacklist and it's a singular hero
that is carved out as if it's not in
context to all the other people who
participated.
And so surely he had grit and surely he
asked a brand new question and surely he
did absolutely an amazing set of things.
But the thing that actually made the
blacklist powerful to get that effort done
is a social act, a communal
act. And that's not,
that's community in a different way
than let's say how Facebook used it.
Facebook uses the term community as a
group of people that we can then monetize.
That's not actual community.
Right?
Community is a group of people who are
held together by a shared of beliefs,
a certain set of purposes,
and then together they can do
things in a meaningful way.
This is important also because I think
it changes how we might think about how
we conceive of our work.
Instead of thinking, what
can I do? You start to think,
who can I organize around a new question
and if you walk away with nothing else
other than that vignette and that story,
it might change how we think and conceive
of how we gather power in our lives.
Because if the story is always a
singular hero on top of a magazine cover,
we miss the real point.
That's individuating something
that is deeply connected.
Now.
Most of us lack that connection,
that ability to kind of think about what
is it that gives me meaning. In fact,
61% of us the data says cover or
hide ourselves. At work covering,
being defined as we actually
don't show up as our true selves.
It's the some of the vignettes
and the and the research.
A guy wearing glasses because
he didn't want to look young.
A young man who didn't talk about how
he wanted to be a co parent because he
didn't want his colleagues to think he
wasn't interested in his career and so on
and so on.
What was most surprising about that
detail that 61% of US cover or hide
ourselves at work is that it didn't
just affect traditional groups,
underserved and under seen people 45%
nearly half of straight white men also say
they cover,
which makes sense if you think about
all the different ways in which people
believe they have to fit to an archetype
or some mirage of normal in order to
actually fit in at work and
as long those were fitting in.
That way we're not actually being our
true selves and from that place of true
sof is where we understand
what gives us meaning,
what gives us purpose and what things
we actually care about. Therefore,
the genesis of our ideas
now,
this lack of social standing when we show
up at work fitting in is the greatest
barrier to belonging. When we lack that
ability to belong as our true selves,
we also lack the ability to
generate ideas that we care about.
I was talking with, um, a banking
executive not so long ago, and,
and this woman was saying she had a really
innovative idea for how to change the
low end of the market, how
to serve the, the deep poor,
the people who use those cash and carry
kind of places where the check cashing
places are used. They typically take
between five and 10% of that check.
And she said she had a way for her bank
to serve that marketplace with less than
half a percent. And I was like,
oh my God, that would change.
You could get a whole bunch
of new customers and it
would change an entire, uh,
group of people's lives, right?
And she says, yeah, yeah,
but I'll never tell the
people sitting at this table.
I looked at her with that sort
of tilting my head and I thought,
why would you not say it?
Why would you not own it?
And it wasn't hard to think about for a
second. She sat there and she said, yeah,
that person,
that person has an Hermes bag,
that person has a such and such Thai.
And she said,
all these people have wealthy backgrounds
and she didn't ever want to show that
she didn't have that same background
because what was she doing?
She was fitting in in order to belong.
And as long as she was fitting in in
order to belong in that half sole kind of
way, she was never also going to claim
that thing that was true for her,
her history and experience her own visions
and hopes based on that history and
experience without social standing,
we lack the ability to actually
create change, real change,
the change we actually
want to see in the world.
Now, um, I've written, ob alluded to it,
I've written two books before on
collaborative work and how power should be
distributed with an organization.
So basically talking about
flat organizations and
breaking down the perimeter of
organizations to open up innovation. And
a lot of times people say, well, you know,
you've studied these business models for
years, you've done innovation for years.
This must be why you care.
And actually the real reason of why I
notice this grouping problem is because of
my own heritage. You see,
when I was 18 years old,
I was actually supposed to get
an arranged marriage. And uh, uh,
I had returned home. In
fact, uh, when I was 18,
I had gone to commuter college and for
the day and returned home and they're my
aunties and uncles and stuff had
filled the house. And if, you know,
Indian families, they're just like all
over the place. And, uh, they had, uh,
been there to tell me that my arranged
marriage was well arranged and, uh,
the sort of terms of the deal were set.
And I had turned to my uncle who was
sort of representing because my father
wasn't in the picture, who's representing
me and are representing our family.
And so did you ask the guy if I could
get an education because I was the only
thing I had ever said. If you could
please make sure that was taken care of,
I would be okay with it.
Because ever since I was four and
a half and move to this country,
I understood my job to be that,
of taking care of my mother and getting
this arranged marriage as a way of
serving the family. And my uncle
had turned to me and said, no,
she will not let me ask because she's
negotiating for house and some other
things.
So her future is taken care of.
She doesn't want to also ask
for your needs and interests.
So I was polite enough to wait until
my aunt, aunties and uncles left.
And then I turned to her and my mother
and I had done this sort of theatrical
thing, which is not my style
normally. Um, and I had,
I had gone to future
business leaders of America.
So the sentence is entirely informed by
future business leaders of America club
in high school. And I
said, I am the product.
You cannot do the deal without me.
So ask the guy if I can get an
education and this will be done.
And I had turned like the
closest thing next to me,
a cardboard box without a lid
or anything like grocery box.
And I grabbed it and I had put
in five books in one outfit,
no toothbrush, no money,
because I didn't have any.
And you can tell my priorities,
right?
Books went outfit and I was just
doing this theatrical thing. I've,
and I'm leaving unless you
change your mind. And um,
I actually thought this
would end in about an hour.
And so I walked down the street to
the local donut shop as one does
carbohydrates,
everything.
And I thought I was just going to wait
it out and then call home and be like,
it's done.
When I called home,
the situation only escalated like,
we're never going to change our mind,
but you come home right now.
And one day turned into two,
two days turned into three and it's,
well,
it's been 30 years and I
got exited from my family,
homeless, educated. Um,
no cash in the pocket kind of thing to
go off and figure out this new direction
in my life.
And,
and that moment my
identity was being defined,
my value to the world,
my ability to create my own space in the
world is being defined by what a group
I belong to in this case being
an Indian or Muslim or woman,
some combination thereof that said,
the only value you have to us in the
world is to serve in way in this box.
That was the first time I saw
groupings and I thought, well,
it's probably true to my family,
but then I would go on and do. Um,
one of my first jobs was as
an Admin at apple and uh,
I showed up in one of those like early
meetings and I was such an eager kid to
want to prove myself and stuff.
And uh, at one time they said, hey,
we're going to brainstorm by x, come
to the meeting, we're going to do this.
And I remember doing all the research I
could find and formulating questions and
showing up and being so excited.
Like you can totally picture it,
right like this that are like Yay and a,
it only took a minute or two and maybe
even three to realize no one was making
eye contact with me because it turns
out in that room it was the Mbas who had
the ability to qualify for having ideas.
Seeing through that category,
not for everyone.
In later jobs it would be engineers where
the people, we expect it to have ideas,
not marketing people.
Ob,
you might recognize that one or in
other jobs it's only the top executive
management team is allowed to have ideas,
not this other group.
And so this thing about groupings ended
up showing up throughout my career and
tech throughout all the different ways
in which I was driving strategy and
innovation.
I'm realizing that's actually the
biggest limiting factor is that we're not
noticing the one thing that
actually counts the individual
that's standing right
in front of us.
Invisible to some,
but purely able to offer that perspective,
that idea that they have.
Sometimes they're invisible to themselves.
I'm not suggesting it's just external,
but it is denying the power of the
singular voice and making invisible that
which has value simply
because the packaging,
not because of the idea.
So I'll fast forward and just point
out that this is actually a trend that
allows us to do innovation,
right?
So apple and Google helped
change the mobile marketplace.
I was around back when companies like
apple or Samsung used to actually choose
the APP.
The term was choosing on deck,
which apps they would put bride one or
two or three apps costing about a million
to $2 million in development,
probably about the same in
sales and marketing expense.
And those companies would then decide,
choose for the consumer.
Here's the thing they would offer.
An apple came along and changed
that developer platforms.
So only costs $10,000 to be able
to participate in that ecosystem,
allowing a marketplace of ideas
to happen in the form of apps.
And then Google came along and
did it one better always. And uh,
and dropped it down to 500 bucks and
change this opportunity for people to come
from anywhere, everywhere.
And be able to participate.
And when I started spotting that,
I was like,
is that a pattern that would allow a
whole bunch of people to suddenly become
available in the marketplace of ideas?
Could the idea transpose the immediate
of a smartphone APP or platform based
model?
And that's when I had actually coined
this term ominus it's part of a,
essentially it's an economic thesis,
right?
It's basically arguing that
value can come from anywhere.
Ideas come from that spot in
the world that each of us stand.
They can now scale and connectedness.
So you can see the two parts only
knows I should not go into marketing.
And uh,
but I was basically arguing this is the
way in which we will create value in the
future.
Now I still believe this, oh,
the bill's not going to work.
Um, it's a really pretty
build, um, the, uh,
the opportunity for each of us to finally
get a chance to actually stand more
deeply in our own truth and like Franklin
be able to ask new questions of our
workforce,
of our work environment.
And even outside that it could change
not only what we individually do,
but what we're able to create together.
I think to those economists
who say we've run out of ideas,
I think they've only counted
about 37% of the ideas,
the ideas that come from
traditional power base,
which in America is mostly white and
mostly male and mostly from places that
sounded like Harvard when they could
actually come from each and every single
one of us. In fact, if I could ask
you to do one little exercise with me,
close your eyes for a second
and think back to that time when you
first were valued just as yourself.
Somebody saw you and said,
this is who you are and it's special or
this is what you can do and that's good.
They saw some light in you,
some shining capacity and
wanted that to come forward.
Imagine now if everyone
was given that same idea
uppity.
I think that's the power
of what we can do next.
That each of us as we stand in that
spot in the world, only we stand in,
we can be rooted, deeply rooted
in our purpose. And as we do that,
it will help us find the people who
care about the same things as we do.
And as we do that, we end up being able
to actually shape the world around us,
to not just include those
opinions that are currently herd,
but the set of opinions that
are everywhere that can shape,
reshape the world to include all of our
voices in a much more equal and fair way.
And also of course allow
us the power to innovate.
So that's what I came to say and share
and the rest of the time is really just
about, um, a chance to do Q
and. A. An ob can come comment.
She probably even has a question knowing
her, but we'll pass along the mic too.
Um, you can ask anything from,
what's it like to write a book?
Because some people like to
ask that question, uh, to go.
Excellent. So just put your hand
up and I'll pass you the light,
the Mike so people can hear it.
Um,
so I'm going to kick off with a question.
So one of the things that intrigued
me about only enos and this sort of,
um,
relationship between the individual and
the groups is that when we talk about
diversity and inclusion, um, we often
talk about specific groups, right?
Like women or gay
people, et Cetera, right?
And as we kind of experienced
at Google this summer,
that can be very exclusionist and
people sort of saying like, well,
why are you giving
privilege to this group?
Or why did that group have privilege
in the first place? And so on.
And so one of the things that I think
is interesting about this is that you
bringing it back to the
individual rather than the group.
So can you talk a little bit about that,
what the implications would be if we
thought about diversity and inclusion in a
different way?
Sure. Um, so in fact, uh,
I felt so bad for the situation that
happened the summer because it was
completely predictable
that if you start doing,
oh we're going to try
to include this group,
it feels to the group on the other side
of the teeter tot that power is being
displaced,
that they're being replaced.
And if we're actually talking
about a limited some of the pie,
then you understand where people
were fighting over that pie.
This model actually says
something different, right?
Which is that as you open
up the opportunity more
opportunity exists just like
that apple example. So let's
just use a specific, there was a,
in fact you helped me find this story.
So one of the stories in the
book is a story of folded.
Does anybody know this story
by any chance? Cheater.
She spread the buck and so fold it is a,
as an online platform that was started,
I'm based out of University of Washington
and they were trying to solve the
problem in the bio
sciences space where um,
if if proteins fold incorrectly,
they basically caused disease bottom line.
And so things like Alzheimer's and stuff
are all diseases caused by misfolded
proteins.
And they were realizing this Udab team
that every research team around the world
was recreating the problem of how proteins
were misfolding in order to do the
actual research they wanted to do. And
they thought, this is kind of silly.
There ought to be like a repository you
can draw on so that the foundational
work is there and people can build on it.
Therefore accelerating the research.
And they started an online app to
basically crowd science this process.
And at first they thought
their first step was, um,
we're going to get PhDs from around the
world. So think globalization talent,
right? And that didn't turn out
to have any breakthroughs at all.
They let it run for almost a year.
And so then I thought, oh, you know,
maybe there's another way.
What if we actually allow anyone,
could we actually allow anyone,
quite possibly everyone to participate?
Why don't we build a game that
would teach you the fundamentals?
Like basically teaching how proteins
fold and then you can take it from there.
And that created more resolve.
But then they realized actually there
was some there watching the game and
noticing that people were crowding
around the people who had degrees from
certain schools or that were men and not
actually noticing who actually was good
at the protein folding problem.
And they could spot the difference
because they themselves had actually,
you know, they were studying
it and they just thought,
what if we actually hide those social
signals and just tune them down so that if
you really want to know, you could
know. But the focus is entirely on,
oh that's working better. And people
can notice that. That was one thing.
And then the other thing they started to
do was they actually just realize they
were rewarding individuals
instead of rewarding group work.
So most work today is complex problem
solving, complex problem solving.
It's not ob sitting by herself
or Nyla for sitting by herself.
It's how we start to play off each other.
And so then as soon as they change the
reward system to be, we all went together.
If we all help each other go through
this thing, they'd share in the credit.
It changed how people actually
responded and what they work.
And then they created
these like breakthroughs.
So I think the problem is most of us have
too many social signals in the way and
we're focusing on that
instead of the work.
And so I don't think about
diversity inclusion as I want. Um,
I want to go recruit x number of people.
It's what problems do
we have and what is the,
what is the mechanism in place that would
allow a whole bunch of people to come
and play with that problem?
So if I'm really practical,
when I was doing consulting work, one of
the things we would do is go in and um,
uh, you know, we'd signed a
contract with the company and say,
we're going to come help
you solve x problem.
And this was typically after they had
failed at it themselves and hired a BCG or
Mckinsey or whatever and
failed at it with them.
And then we were in the
room and we would say,
we're going to be in charge
of the process. They would,
of course not their
head because by the way,
who wants to be in charge of the process
and completely signed off to that,
right? Like without a thought.
And then the first day we'd say,
well we're going to send out an email to
anyone in the company and he, you know,
like as broad of a group as possible.
Sometimes the entire
company roster and say,
anybody who wants to come
help us with this can come.
And they would always have this like
total look of panic go across their face.
Like, I don't want that ad mat or the
salesperson who's not happy or that,
you know,
like it's almost like a thought that was
going through your head is I don't want
the crazy and I'm putting that in
air quotes for a reason. Right.
I don't want the crazy or the wild one
in the room because we have a process to
run. And I'm like, trust us,
we'll actually get there.
And as soon as you could have all that
difference around the room and allow each
different to actually have their own
voice to create the space for that.
So it could be sometimes we had post its
and let people have their ideas and it
turns out the posts that's came from
a person who had relatively low power.
But as soon as you disassociated
the power status to the idea,
you could see the idea for what it
was. Then all of a sudden two, three,
four weeks later we'd have this
breakthrough in the room. It always,
I mean always I say this universally came
from that crazy and wild person in the
room and so how do we do that
then for all of our organizations,
how do we actually start to go take
down the signals, tune it down?
So how do we recruit engineering people
without knowing that they're a woman
first?
Right.
The data says that if we don't know that
we're more likely to use that person's
code. So how do we just
engineer more in the system,
a way to tune down social signals and so
that easy practical thing of using post
its in a room to generate ideas is to
have going around the room because we're
more likely to dismiss an idea based
on power status. Would be an easy one.
There's probably a hundred
of those methods that could
just be streamlined into
the business that would allow us to
actually see and contribute those ideas.
Soon as you focus on the
ideas and not on the person.
I think we start to change things
too,
and by the way,
the best protein folder in their set
was an admin assistant for Manchester,
England,
so
who by the way,
it's not,
it's not irrelevant to this given
the climate of sexual harassment.
She had left the industry because as a
nurse she had experienced so much sexism
that she actually left the medical field.
This is a pattern that we've seen
over and over again in recent weeks.
If you read all the vignettes of the
stories of people leaving Hollywood or
people leaving tech, it's so
much sexist. I'm just, you know,
at some point you're like, okay,
okay, I give up, I'll leave, I'll,
I'll tone down my ambitions.
I'll go to more female oriented careers
and of course that's why women don't
have as much power and
status in industries.
Really. We answered everything.
Are you guys just really shocked?
We have one here too.
Okay.
I guess I have a question about unlocking
the onliness early on and what was her
name again? Oh, sorry. I'm
Bridget. Bridget. If you know,
if most of the conversation
has been centered around
like your professional life,
how can you catch this early on?
So I'm thinking about my little sister
who's in college and when I went to visit
her I was disturbed again by the amount
of Greek life and kind of like the group
thing that centers around that and kind
of like how can I help her unlock her
ugliness earlier on? So that's my
question. Stay away from it. How Fun,
but not too much.
Yeah. So it's, I think one of
the things early on in life,
we're often trying to
figure out how to fit in.
So we're actually giving up ourselves
along that process and we're just doing it
for basic survival. Right? So
in Maslow's hierarchy of needs,
the bottom two levels of
the food shelter things,
the top two levels are about self
expression and self actualization,
which is where ideas come from.
In the middle is this big block,
the biggest block of the, of the thing.
And it's belonging. So the question is,
do we understand how to find people
who care about the same things as us?
Most of us are actually socialized
to kind of look and say, okay,
where are people already gathered?
And then do we join in without
much intentional thought
about that's not really
my people.
Right?
And so this question about who are we
to one another is a question we need to
learn to ask like who am I in this mix?
And then who are we to one another?
And if you're asking yourself, gosh, I
really don't feel like I belong here,
maybe your sister really loves it,
right?
But to ask that and learn that skill
about who am I in relationship to this?
And uh, I had a young
entrepreneur who is, um,
I think she was like 20 something when
she asked me this question and she said
she had gotten her phd.
She taught is a very accomplished
young entrepreneur, um,
was a yoga fanatic and had a boyfriend
that she was thinking about Mary.
And she said,
in order for me to decide what's next,
which of these four things do I
have to cut? Should I quit teaching?
Do I quit doing my entrepreneurial
stuff that my phd is based on?
Do I stop all my relationships because
that's such a distraction and should I
quit yogurt, Yogi stuff? Because that's
also a distraction. And I was like,
why don't you do all four and live in
the Venn diagram of everything that is
you? And maybe because she was actually
doing really cutting edge science stuff,
which allows a cell to act like a
heart and so on. So it's incredibly,
has really strong ethical implications
for if you can grow things from nothing.
Right? Um, and I said,
maybe it's your Yogi,
since that will actually help guide your
ethical usage of this stuff because it
will remind you how connected we
are and what those decisions are.
Maybe your relationship to your students
will remind you that you're trying to
teach the next generation about those
same set of ethical implications,
not just the pure science
of it. And so on. Some,
maybe all of those things actually can
belong together because she was really
trying to figure out how to fit
herself into a pigeonhole thing.
It's the greatest thing we can do is to
actually notice all of the person and to
say, um, you know, what you
really seem to care about is x, Y,
and Z and B that,
um,
I like to say that most of us can't
understand our own onlyness. Um,
because we're living it, it's so obvious
to everyone else what we care about,
but it's actually kinda hard cause
you're in the fun of it. You're,
you're literally like mashed up
against the glass of it. Right?
And so friends can say, this is, you
know, something that you care about this.
Oh,
he totally gets me too.
So I'm like waiting for her to
tell me my loneliness for a second.
But it's like a light bulb above
your head when you walk into a room,
the whole room changes. So
if that light bulb is, um,
tamarind orange versus neon orange,
it's a different thing in that room.
Or you know, Mallory blue. Right? And
so if your friends can say to you,
this seems to be this thing you really
care about, it helps reflect it back.
And so maybe that's the one thing you
can do for her is to help notice what is
it that's so true to her
history and experience as
well as her visions and hopes
even something that's just a, a thread
she's ultimately going to pull on to help.
Okay.
Hi, my name is Jason Jason. Um,
I noticed that one barrier
for participation is,
is the ability to speak the
language folks employee.
If you are in a room
with a bunch of Mbas and,
and if you don't have the background
that you can hardly really talk with them
in, in, in those, in all those jargons
that they use. Same for engineers.
If you are a not, if you don't
have a computer science background,
often times you don't really
know what they're talking about.
And when you talk in your own language
and they can easily dismiss your ideas.
Do you have any comment on that?
No, it's, so language is one
of those invisible, um, ways
in which we group people.
Absolutely. We use jargon to say we're in
this industry in this way. And in fact,
the Udab team, that was one of their
big insights. Um, it was, uh, Adrian,
I interviewed him here. He actually
worked at Google X for awhile. Um,
and he said to me,
we were sitting around with one of the
top physicists in the world and he used
absolutely no jargon and that's what
gave him the clue to go from PhDs to go
solve this problem to citizen science.
That was the shift is Dragan was
becoming the barrier to actually allowing
people to innovate.
It's one of the reasons why in the last
five or so years actually is very little
innovation jargon. I'm
simplifying my own, um,
choices and, and I'm doing that
because I'm trying to make,
I'm trying to get past my own bullshit,
right? And I mean that and the greatest,
like we go through all this
training to learn stuff,
but sometimes you have to
go, okay, actually know that.
So now how do I communicate it?
In a much simpler and more elegant way.
So you've actually reached
a really profound truth,
which is most of the time most of us
are using jargon to say I'm in this club
and that, and that can mean
I'm educated and credentialed.
It can mean I'm an engineer and not one
of your marketing people that doesn't
talk this way.
Right.
And my husband's a chip designer and I'm
fascinated what I read his resume cause
I don't understand most of it.
And he asked me for some help recently
and looking at it and I was like,
well I can give you like Seth
the gist of it. You know,
like if the sentence structures right
or if like the main ideas popping out,
but I can't really talk to
you about anything else.
You might want to have
somebody else do that part.
But I was realizing like we do this
thing where we create separations,
partially say this is the club by men.
And the question is when
we're talking in meetings,
then maybe we could actually kind of what,
find a way to tone down the jargon. I,
you can even say that, right. Hey,
jargon might be getting in the way
for us finding a breakthrough idea.
So why don't we just figure
out how to dial it down,
which is why that posted example.
And I could probably give
you another 100 examples.
Like that can be the way to get past
language choices. It's intentionality.
It's intentionality.
That's a great question.
Hi, my name is Ada. I can lean
man Ada Lovelace. Ah, yeah.
All right. Okay. Yeah,
if you want to say that
I am not named after that and mark about
the pouting palindrome cause my mom's
name is Ena,
which is also a palindrome.
I don't know where she got
that idea from. Um, anyway. Um,
well there's an onlyness story there.
Uh,
I can only imagine the courage
you had to have, um, you know,
the to speak in that room are people who,
if I can give you eye contact,
um,
as Asian women died myself like that.
At first my English
wasn't even smooth enough.
And going into the room where people
taller and bigger, they'll guy,
I have often had that experience. And, um,
sometimes I really tried to fit in,
in order to make someone like notice,
like I'm here and actually here I'm
curious like from your experience,
like how to give courage in that moment
and how do you even make your voice
heard?
Because I'm actually believed that you
need to kind of make yourself belong.
Then you take a step back and show that,
by the way,
I also have this uniqueness,
but I don't know,
maybe there is another way to do it.
The tension of how do we belong to a
group that we have to influence and also
assert our own ideas.
So one way is to actually have an
invisible network always there with you.
So there's a group of people
that you have to get along with,
but you can actually build an invisible
network of people in the room with you.
So for example, um, I belong to,
it's, it's in the, it's in the book.
I forget too. I'm a chapter
for this group called the list.
And it was a group of
women started, uh, um,
trying to figure how to change the
women ratio on stages in board rooms,
et Cetera, um, entrepreneurial
settings. And so, um, the,
it was a private list and
so you'd ask questions like,
one of my favorite ones was,
so this one VC always smells my hair.
Should I worry about the
smelling of the hair?
And other people shared, actually that guy
smells. Everyone here, it's genderless.
That guy has a hair fetish.
And so the weirdest thing to discover,
but it became the whisper
network, um, made visible, right?
So then all of us were starting to
share stories about what was working in
venture funding, who was doing
what. It became the back channel.
So at any given point, I could be in a
meeting saying, I'm experiencing this.
Anyone have ideas?
And Asta Guide.
Within a couple of seconds someone
would be like, why don't you try this?
And it would become this.
There's,
there's this invisible group of 499
other people who are available on call
through texting to be able to
help me get through my situation.
And it could be here,
you might end up choosing five people
who are often in that room or in that
setting on your team and say,
hey,
could we actually figured out
how to help each other more,
be more intentional about helping
each other's ideas get promoted.
So maybe if somebody else's in
the room with you, they could say,
you know what Ada just said is really
worth expanding on so that people then
draw more attention back to your idea.
If she felt it was like getting
skipped over because of that,
you could find ways of building a network
despite the room that you have to be
in.
Does that make sense?
So it's an intentionality of
design of who else could join you,
whether they're in the room or not.
And um,
figuring out how to have that set of
resources available to you that ends up
improving your social standing.
Because now you don't get to feel like
the Weirdo in the room because at any
given point you have a posse invisible
to the room that is always got your back.
And as long as you have that
social standing, you have
more confidence going in.
And you know,
I ended up leaving home that day,
but I showed up on community
college campus the next day.
And literally I walked down
to the financial aid office.
I knew the guy who happened around
the financial aid office and said,
so this just happened. And he said, oh.
And he literally took my hand and he
walked me around the campus and he
convinced three people to give me jobs.
One was a coding job,
one was an usher job, one was an
accounting job, the usher job,
I could do Saturday nights.
So I could still study the a county
job was a Friday afternoon job,
or once a week I would sit there and do
the history museum on campus accounting
and the other job I could do basic coding
to ultimately build a matriculation
program.
I could do it flexible hours.
So between classes I could show up and
do an hour worth of work here and there.
I literally pieced together in
that one afternoon by ability.
But this person wanted
me to have an education.
So my family did not cause
they saw me through one lens,
but this person belonged to
a different group. Right?
He believed in the same thing I believed,
which is that a woman, despite her,
I mean a person despite her gender can
have an education and here is something
he could do to come lend support.
And as soon as you end up walking away
from the people who don't believe in you
that you actually don't belong
to in any kind of real way,
you will ultimately find the people
to whom and with whom you do belong.
That walkway,
that gang plank is treacherous.
Like you feel like you're
going to end up nowhere,
but you ultimately do get there.
So that's what I think gives me courage
to studying all that and seeing that
every single one of the 300 stories had
to walk the gang plank and then they
ended up with a group of people who
actually believed in them and could stand
with them.
Hi, I had a question about it
turned not to be calmer now. Uh,
so thank you for the
topic. I think I, I have,
I'm a new new to Google and I think I
sometimes experience some of the things
that you're talking about.
I think a harder I,
what these people have been asking is
how do you create your credibility in
front of those people who are looking for
it is not necessarily about, you know,
the like how much, how much language
about is you hire and whatnot.
I think what you're trying to say
is, okay, how am I make some, how,
how can I be more credit credible
to this audience? Wow. Why,
why establishing their own
credibility with, with, with the,
with the MBA degrees and whatnot. Yeah.
And the second point I want to make, make,
make,
make.
It is I think what you just explained
in the previous question was about the
heart offered your time to look for
mentors who can guide you through this
process. And, and it's
still at the end of the day,
used to how to walk that path to
make yourself credit card, you know,
establishing credibility for,
for these people at the group
you're trying to do the work with.
Yeah. It's a beautiful set of reflections.
What was your name by the way?
I'll read you a beachy, I'll
bet you I'd be shit. Um,
so, so one, one little,
I'm sorry, your first one.
Go back to it for a second.
It was credibility, right?
We're trying to establish credibility.
Most of us have been conditioned to
believe that the outside world gets to
identify for us whether or
not we have value to add.
This is a different thing to do,
which is to believe that you
already have something to add.
You already have some value to give.
And so that first step is how
do we conceive of ourselves
in such a way that we
understand even if we're not educated
or rapport where whatever that we have
value to offer and,
and tilt the system and then say as
I valued myself, I will get valued.
So just standing in that truth is probably
the biggest step because I mean I do
this all the time. I had,
I was just emailing with a
girlfriend and a and saying,
I'm having a really hard time with some
of the speaking work I'm doing because
she said,
well,
what you're trying to say is this is the
biggest manager meant idea ever, right?
Which is if we're going to be able
to create ideas out of people,
and that's the entire economy.
What you're saying is only next is
the biggest management idea ever.
Because as you lead people and
recognize that their individuality,
you will actually create the kinds of
teams, organizations, blah, blah, blah,
that will actually create outcomes.
That is a huge idea.
And I wrote back to her and I said,
yeah, that's really easy if you say it,
but by the way,
the whole world hasn't started yet.
So for me to assert that as a truth
feels crazy for you to assert that as a
truth does not. And then I shut
the computer and I went, yeah.
So I'm having a hard time owning my own
laziness. Right. Totally. It's just,
it's this weird thing cause
what I'm waiting for us,
I'm credentialed moment to say
you're allowed to claim something
as an idea. And so, so it's just a,
it's just a flip to actually say I can't,
I can actually claim that and
there's enough data and the system,
there's enough signals in the system
to say that's it's based on evidence.
The research has been done, the social
science behind it backs at. Right.
But I still can't make myself say it.
Does that make sense?
So I understand what you're
talking about about influence,
but the first step is about how do you
conceive of yourself because it changes
the value equation.
So I think actually for
those us who have children,
that's probably the biggest gift
we can give our kids is to not have
expectations or what they're going to do,
but just give them the confidence that
whatever they choose to do, they can do.
So. Yeah. Alright. We have
time for one more question.
He wants to bring it home.
Okay.
Otherwise we're going to end it on that.
And thank you so much for coming in.
[inaudible]. Thank you for those of
you who joined us on the livestream.
Thanks.
Thanks for us to great conversation.